you're right something's missing who's
nothing but hold on this is taking
forever that's right kids
my old Star Wars curtain cave had
forever video where I talked about the
trailers it might as well have it for
the movie review it only makes sense
Star Wars The Force awakens I can't
believe I'm saying that
so Star Wars The Force awakens is the
next chapter in the Star Wars saga this
takes place after Return of the Jedi
you're now seeing the world you never
thought you'd ever see now this is gonna
be super spoiler free no spoilers here
watch enjoy and then watch the movie and
enjoy that too I think I just ruined it
by saying I like this cuz I did it's
gonna be tough to review this movie with
no spoilers but it has got to happen
basically I'm gonna tell you what you
knew from the trailer you have Finn and
he was part of the first order and now
he's left it and he meets up with Rey
down on a desert planet of jakku and
then they just get mingled into this new
adventure of Star Wars and then there's
kylo Ren who's a big baddie and he's an
[ __ ] at vague like I said no spoilers
let's talk about what I liked about this
movie first of all the action sequences
are great we've seen that JJ Abrams
could do great action sequences he just
has great cinematography the sound
editing is fantastic cuz it's all so
familiar not only is it an exciting
action sequence happening but you're
like those sound effects I grew up on
them oh my god it's all new it's blowing
my mind you can't help but have the
nostalgia bomb hit you over the head hit
you in the face but like the force just
let it in and the characters were great
too alright John boyega and Daisy Ridley
have great bright careers ahead of them
if there were new characters that were
gonna introduce to the Star Wars saga as
the main characters of a movie I'm glad
it to them they're fantastic actors they
bring to strength where they need it the
heart where they need it the
vulnerability when they need to and
there's just great performers and some
of the actors you heard were in this
movie they're in it briefly and you get
the feeling is like because they want to
be in the Star Wars movies max Vaughn
see dowser cameo don't let anyone tell
you different and kylo Ren surprised me
in this movie I thought kylo ren's just
gonna be kind of like Vader to point out
he's just a little more human when you
start hearing them talk you just notice
it's not a big brooding voice for the
sake of a big brooding menacing voice I
mean it does have a voice box that makes
it sound blade sounds just like it
sounds in the trailer but you can tell
that the tone of it is too easy still a
human being no the big baddie with the
mask in a movie is actually easy
character not saying Darth Vader wasn't
a character I was just surprised that in
this day and age they had a masked
villain for the sake of big and scary
that was and a big shout out is
happening because this big shout out is
happening Harrison Ford as Han Solo was
great I thought Han Solo was gonna be in
this movie kind of shoehorned into it to
kind of take these other
Neuer cast members under his wing kind
of like hay audience here they're the
new ones now we're handing the tour show
over you can trust them and because one
of the best most beloved characters in
the previous Star Wars trilogy did that
then we trust him all right Han Solo if
you say so and while that is kind of his
function in this movie he is still a
character he's out there on the
adventures with them he is doing stuff
he didn't have to do that and they
totally did and it was great I saw that
scene where Han and Leia are hugging in
the trailers like one blip and other
alright there's gonna do that you're
gonna see han and Leia on scene and it's
gonna be Hanalei for the sake of hundred
Leia he's just gonna be a cheap way to
be like Ernest Elgin and while there are
some easy nostalgia moments in this
movie that's just not one of them there
are some great moments with Han and Leia
where you're like oh your characters and
you have history again with Han Solo I
love the fact that he played old Han
stolen when I say that it's not that he
played Han Solo thirty years ago again
just as an older guy he played Han Solo
who has lived thirty years of a life
since the last time we saw him he's a
little older he's a little wiser but he
does have that Han Solo edge that's
character evolution I love that if he
was just the same guy he was thirty
years ago I'd be disappointed I'd be
like why hasn't he grown at all is he's
just a big manchild leave that to the
youtubers we're supposed to be the
immature one smugglers are supposed to
be responsible there are some characters
people who look it's gonna be such a
badass character they're barely in it
like I already said max von sydow I was
kind of a cameo in this movie but I'm
gonna tell you right now Captain phasma
did exactly jack [ __ ] Captain phasma
didn't do much at all and I was kind of
disappointed about that domhnall gleeson
was great but he was exactly what I
wanted him to be so it was kind of easy
to say he was great he was I just wanted
this young imperial officer dick guess
what he was he was a young officer dick
for the first order Bravo you've pleased
me and po-po was one of my favorite
characters in the movie I didn't see him
enough I loved when I saw him and I want
to see him more I just didn't see him
enough immediately gravitate this dude
you're like I'd hang out with you man I
just would I cannot believe you're gonna
be apocalypse because in a galaxy far
far away if they do have a dictionary
the picture next to the word likeable is
that guy and one of the best things in
this movie for me is something I think
some people are going to have a big
problem with and that is you do not have
all of your questions answered by the
end of this movie some of your questions
are answered but you end this movie with
ten more question however there's going
to be more it's part one of a trilogy
and I love that
love the intrigue I love the fact that
when the next trailer comes out I can be
like oh my gosh it's left up here so I
think it's gonna go there and oh what
are they doing you couldn't tell by now
I love me speculating and I just like
doing it and this movie has some great
humor too you know with JJ Abrams you
knew it was going to have humor and I've
never seen humor like this work in a
Star Wars movie the prequels tried to be
funnier but it just came across as
awkward nothing really landed and the
original trilogy doesn't have as much
humor although it does have humor not as
much as the force awakens the force
awakens has more humor but more humor
that landed and it made the movie has a
whole feel a bit more relatable and a
bit more human never seen that much of
that side of Star Wars before and I was
glad I saw it now one of the things that
helps bring the og original trilogy Star
Wars fans into this movie one of the
things that needs to be touched on all
the nostalgia in this movie and that's
the familiar plot points from the other
Star Wars movies in this movie a few
times this movie or like I recognize
that oh I've seen that before I have
seen that before and well there's a part
of me that doesn't understand that they
did that for the introduction for Star
Wars Episode seven alright it's been
thirty years a lot of fans kind of had a
rough patch with those prequels alright
we'll let them know that we're going
back to the old ways I feel like in the
sequel we'll get more new things but it
does have to be addressed out on more
than a few occasions you're like I've
seen that I kind of equate it like this
it's like every side scroller
Castlevania game after Symphony of the
Night was pretty much Symphony of the
Night with a new skin on it doesn't
change the fact that they're all fun to
play and they're all great it's just
they're still the same game I mean I can
make excuses all day long as to how I
can deal with it and how I sit and how I
think it's okay that's just for me the
point is I need to inform you that it's
in here and if those familiar as plot
devices from other Star Wars movies
being in this movie is too much for you
well you just need to know that my job
here is to inform you not think like you
the end of this movie the last act the
thing that the good guys have to do is
really familiar you're gonna be like
I've seen exactly this but it's not
really the point for the end of the
movie I mean it gives everyone something
to do to get to the point the point
being kylo Ren in the confrontation with
him that's the point and it was great
cuz this lightsaber fight man I feel
like that's not a spoiler you knew there
was gonna be a lightsaber fight in this
movie it's great it's great because it's
not super choreographed it's not
flashing it's really dirty it's really
gritty it's just really really feels
like a couple of people just hacking at
each other to try to kill and survive
the most important thing I can tell you
is manage your expectations for this
movie if you defy the force awaken
all ready you're gonna walk out of this
movie disappointing because it is a
great movie with flaws that are
noticeable and it's probably that
because it's springboarding off of the
original trilogy which are great movies
with flaws that are noticeable nostalgia
aside admitted there's that but a movie
can still be a flawed movie and still be
great most movies I consider great
definitely have flaws guys in the end
the force awakens had great characters
great exciting action it's a wonderful
reintroduction to the Star Wars universe
and it gives it revitalizing energy by
harkening back to the old and giving us
some of the new there's a lot in here
that I loved I had a fun time but I also
had a surprisingly emotional time to
walk out of this movie or like that
movie hit a lot of emotions for me I've
heard some people say it to turn your
brain off fun movie I can't say a movie
hit so many emotions for me and I
actually started welling up in a few
scenes and nabila goes don't turn your
brain I know those are two different
movies I'm talking about if I do that
there is a scene in this movie where my
eyes just welled up and got hot and I
just grin and I was like that is amazing
I don't know if I was like welling up I
was just getting emotional and I wasn't
sad or anything it was just a powerful
scene that I really really liked and I'm
glad it was in this movie the force
awakens was personally what I wanted it
to be and if you keep your expectations
in check and know that it is a movie you
can walk out of the force awakens having
one of the most enjoyable theatrical
experiences you have had in 2015 and
I'll say without batting an eyelash star
wars the force awakens is awesome
tacular
if you want me to do the objective rail
for people who aren't Star Wars fans I'd
probably give it by it on blue right but
the nostalgia factor for me that worked
in this movie for me as a Star Wars Band
just brought me right back and that puts
it up because this my review and I can
do that versus Star Wars The Force
awakens have you seen it what did you
think about it but if eat that comment
below let me know and yeah there's a
spoiler video coming out that I will do
for this so if there's something like I
wanted you to talk about that I probably
considered it a spoiler and I will talk
about it later but as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more